great so we are ready to begin here
thank you all for joining again today
welcome
to the first session of bioinformatics
for precision oncology
precision medicine is changing the way
we
understand diagnose and treat cancer
the transformation is driven by high
throughput
molecular data from patients animal
models
and large scale cell line experiments
in this program we will explore how high
throughput data can be analyzed
to study the genomic background of
cancer
or comics data that describes the basic
biology associated with
cancer onset development and outcomes
and see
how large scale data sets collected from
clinical trials provide an opportunity
to better understand this condition and
improve the precision
of clinical oncology my name is beepsha
biswas
and i am the omix logic community
manager
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users
who are part of a bioinformatics
community managed by fine biotech
for those of you joining us for the
first time
i wanted to share about the omixlogic
programs
that are a result of a close
collaboration between buyingbiotech
and innovative big data analytics
company based
in the us and numerous academic
institutions
that have participated in content
evaluation
curriculum review and project design as
a result
the omics logic programs have been
thoroughly
tested around the world and are known to
lead to excellent
outcomes for students with minimal
bioinformatics background
including biology and biomedical studies
majors
as well as faculty interested in
bioinformatics
data science and biomedical research
omits logic is an international program
that is running
in five different regions with over 10
000 users around the world due to this
fast growth
our team is working with local and
regional coordinators that are helping
refine local program logistics
and leverage our online training
resources
adapting them to the needs of students
and researchers around the world
the goal of the omics logic programs is
to provide
training in bioinformatics enabling
independent research guided by
mentor and pure example developing a
growing community with shared passion
for data-driven research and
appreciation
of citizen science enabling students
clinicians
and faculty of all backgrounds to
develop
novel and independent research using
latest technology
in life and data sciences we will
combine
online sessions like today self-guided
study materials and
practical assignments for an immersive
experience that has proven to be
effective
in our well-known and respected omix
logic programs
the program will contain online sessions
courses on the basics of various type of
data like
genomics transcriptomics etc
as well as project data sets that come
from high
impact publications on various aspects
of cancer biology
so the first platform that i would want
you all to get started with
is learn dot omics logic so
the platform is learn
dot omicslogic.com
i'm posting the link to the platform in
the chat box
this platform comes with a variety of
resources
so let us go ahead and check what this
platform is about
so let me go ahead and show you
so this is the learn platform and i'll
post the link
again in the chat box so that you all
can go ahead with me
and start with this platform so you'll
find that there is
a login option here and once you click
on the login
option it will take you to the sign up
page and here you have the option to
create an account either with your own
email id so i'm already logged in
or you can also use any of the social
logins
so once you are logged into the platform
you would be directly
going to the courses now we have
added all of the courses here into
different lessons
so if any of you were already familiar
with the edu platform
there we had courses divided as
introduction to genomics genomics one
and two what we have done with the learn
platform
is added to the introductory courses but
also added
all the several different stages of the
courses
into different lessons so you can start
with
just lesson one and progress so all
participants will have full access to
the platform and to all of the courses
so any of the courses marked with a star
that you see here
are premium courses and can be accessed
either as part of the program
or via a license which we are going to
be talk about
at the very end so there are a lot of
free resources as well for
everybody to get started with so please
feel free to
explore this platform and we do not only
have courses we also have
projects like these as well as we have
integrated
coding in r and python as part of this
training program
so without much ado and waiting for you
to
get started what i'm going to be
introducing you next to is the server
platform so i hope that
you are are logging into learn.xlogix so
the server platform is the next resource
that all of you will have access to as
part of the program
and we are going to be talking more
about how to utilize
this platform during this entire one
month training
and for our omixlogic participants to
reach out to us
i'm sorry about this one we have a slack
channel so this
channel is only open for all of our
participants
and the participants can actually go
ahead
and join this group so we will send out
personal invites to all participants
this will just
make sure that you're able to connect
with our team
as part of this full one month training
so please make sure
that you are registered for the program
and you're receiving all of these emails
from our
end and there are also two other groups
that i would like
to invite all of the participants and
everybody who joins any of our programs
too
so we have a group on linkedin where you
can connect with
other members from all around the world
there are clinicians faculty students
also administrators so please feel free
to join any of these groups and also a
group we have
is on facebook so you can find us on
either of these
social media channels and follow us
there now let me go back to the
presentation quickly
and introduce you to our trainers
so we have dr harpreet kaur who is a
certified omix logic trainer and expert
by information
she will guide the hands-on sessions and
assist participants with
projects and analysis during the program
her area of specialization is in cancer
genomics and machine learning
dr mohit mazumdar is our omix logic
project mentor
and an expert in big data computational
analysis
he has a phd in computational biology
and over 10 years of experience working
with
industry and academia elia brodsky
is the co-founder and ceo of pine
biotech
in his current role he has extensive
experience working together with
industry and academic partners
who are applying multi-omics integration
and bioinformatics to a variety of
biotechnology and clinical applications
we also have clinton kona who is joining
us
as one of the bioinformatics trainer for
this program
he has a master in bioinformatics from
the university of guelph
and a masters in cellular and molecular
medicine from the university of
otawa now i would like to invite
dr mazumdar to share more about the
omits logic precision
oncology program over to you dr mazumdar
thank you everyone
thank you deepsha and hello everyone
so just a second let me share my screen
hello everyone thank you for joining
this session and my name is mohit
mazumba
i have done my master's
in bioinformatics from jamie amelia
islamiyah and i did my phd and major
research work at
jawala nehru university india and then
after finishing
my phd i was able to work with uh with a
bioinformatics company
helping pharmaceutical companies to
work who are working on different
bioinformatics challenges
related to big data and applying machine
learning and data science
applications of data science in research
so in my cur in the in this current role
in my control i'm working with
universities and i'm working with
students
and research uh to be able to work on
several of bioinformatics research
problems that we are seeing and uh also
i'm
contributing in data science related
curriculums and
biological research of uh at different
levels of education
so uh talking about the session today
and
about the program and the context of
this program
so one of the major objective of this
omixlogic program
is to be able to learn from the
asynchronous materials
different and the application of
different omics technology
and also learn from the example projects
however omics logic oncology research
program
the one that we have designed is helps
researchers
and participants to not just learn from
the examples and learn about the
different omics technology
but to also explore the hugely available
public data
on ngs cancer research uh but
however i mean oftentimes it's it's kind
of flick really hard
we find it like really hard to find the
right kind of omics data
for maybe precision oncology research
project
so learning about the impact of
ngs and this explosive growth of
publicly available data
one just wonder like you just have to
wonder about that
how much data is available and where you
can find the
rna-seq data sets on cancer and you know
start
exploring what kind of experiments are
uh have done
uh to answer some of the important
questions that
sort of data is which is being utilized
by the pharma industry
and uh and the healthcare sector so we
kind of have compiled an um
post here where you can find uh
where you can find good data sets and
work on and look at the available
resources that are
that have generated on also the
scientists who have generated and the
research labs who have generated
these data sets so during this time
interacting with many students during
our like omics logic educational
programs
we realize that the need for high
quality data sources
that anyone can learn from and use
so uh defining good data so good data is
the data from
collections that follow a certain level
of
metadata annotation with minimal
restrictions
and easy access to the files so
for example details of phenotypic
information associated with samples
as well as the file size or sequencing
instruments that are being used those
are all important factors
so another criteria would be the number
of replicates
where they have whether they are
technical or biological
so some of the best repositories that
answers these questions
and like have those samples are compiled
in this blog post
so i'll just let me
share this link with all of you so that
you can visit this blog post
there you go um so as i was telling you
that working on
example data sets so some of the example
data sets that are already available and
and we will be talking about those uh
those projects
is uh like modeling precision medicine
so working on cell line data sets
and then working on example data sets
followed by
some of uh the other repositories like
uh
in one of the upcoming workshops that
will be happening in april
in collaboration with all india
institute of medical sciences we'll be
working on tcga
lymphoma data and and then going through
the the publicly available data
specialized
for a department of pathology who are
working on
patient samples related to that so some
of the applications can be directly
you know you can find directly on
publicly available data which will be
utilized
in this in this uh program so we
will be really really happy to uh
for you to explore these data sets and
come up with your own research questions
and we'll be happy to
work with you on your research problem
uh problems throughout this
uh program so with this information uh
i'd like to pass it on to clinton uh who
is here
and will be one of the omex logic
trainers to talk
helping us learn about the different
aspects of oncology research
so over to you clinton thank you dr
muslim
let me share my screen
all right
so precision medicine is changing
the way we understand diagnose and treat
cancer
this transformation is driven by high
throughput molecular data from patients
animal models and large scale cell line
experiments
today we will introduce you to the
bioinformatics um for precision oncology
program
but before we do that let me share a few
points about my background
and the reason why bioinformatics is
central to the trans
to translational research in oncology
my name is clinton kuna i completed my
bachelor's degree at carnegie mellon
university
where i discovered my passion for
research later on i decided to continue
learning about life sciences as a result
i now have two master's degrees one from
the university of guelph
and the other from the university of
ottawa since i was
interested in translational
bioinformatics i did a masters
in bioinformatics and another one in
molecular medicine
as a result i am familiar with
biomedical research
as well as data analytics
so cancer is an extremely heterogeneous
disease
even though the war on cancer was
announced 70
years ago that was announced 70 years
ago
brought upon many advances in our
understanding
of the basic mechanisms of tumor growth
and metastasis
it is also clear that the current
research did not solve the problem
on the contrary we are learning more and
more about this complex condition
to show how complex cancer is let me
give you an example
from my past research experience there
are several proteins that play different
roles within certain contexts
for example c20 like kinase or slk
is a protein that plays an important
role in cellular processes
such as proliferation migration and
apoptosis
it affects embryo development and is
shown to play a role in tumor genesis
this was studied in a new
induced mammary tumor model within mice
these experiments showed that slk
knockout mice
developed tumors faster and showed an
increased
expression of sox10 an important
biomarker in cancer
however in my own research we studied
slk in mouse embryonic fibroblasts
where slk knockout reduces focal
adhesion turnover
it turns out that slk plays different
roles depending on the context
even though this contradicts the other
study
it also shows how complex the biology of
cancer can be
and how careful we have to be with
experimental design
and data analysis to truly understand
its pathogenesis research
on slk is ongoing this is similar to
cancer
every cancer is different and it's a
challenge to determine
where whether those where those
differences exist
we need more advanced methods to
determine why a knockout reduces a
process
in one context but increases it in
another my master's thesis
gave me a glimpse of how bioinformatics
can be used to study oncology
and the skills i acquired enabled me to
use more sophisticated models
and methods of analysis such as machine
learning
therefore based on my first masters i
decided to pursue
a masters in bioinformatics to learn
those complex skills
pure biology is good but having the data
analysis skills
to create meaningful relationships
definitely solves major problems
that can be translated into applications
within medicine
bioinformatics has exposed me to other
fields due to its interdisciplinary
nature such as statistics engineering
and mathematics
so now let me pass it on to dr harpreet
to talk more about her research and her
experiences
thank you clinton let me share my screen
hello everyone my name is harpreet kaur
and i have a phd in bioinformatics i
have done my doctoral from
csir institute of microbial technology
india
and jnu new delhi let me give you some
glimpse
how bioinformatics can be helpful in
identifying biomarker
or signature for a specific malignancy
by taking some examples from my research
work
my phd research was on biomarker
discovery
for diagnosis and prognosis of the liver
cancer
using bioinformatics
so for the first part of this project
we used last scale transcriptomics data
to identify
a diagnostic biomarker panel for the
hepatocellular carcinoma which is
primary liver malignancy
here we employed 30 data set containing
nearly 4 000 sample
to elucidate transcriptomic signature
for the diagnosis and the prognosis of
the liver cancer
particularly hepatocellular carcinoma
using
various bioinformatics techniques in the
second part
we employed nine data set containing
nearly 350 calendrio carcinoma
133 edison non-tumorous and 90
hepatocellular carcinoma
samples so here we scrutinize
a three gene based signature which is
specific to the clancho carcinoma
implementing various data mining
techniques like
random forest svm extra logistic
regression etc
in the next part of the our project
we use transcriptomics and methylation
data
of the hepatocellular carcinoma pacing
to identify
early and the late stage basis so
here we use tcga data of 350 scc samples
and elucidate 51 features that include
30 rna transcripts
and 20 methylation cpg site to
discriminate early in the late stage of
some
late stage samples of scc
so in my current role i am omits logic
bioinformatics trainer with pan bartek
i am assisting participants to learn
about data analysis
machine learning and visualization in
application of
large data set used in the biomedical
research
beside i am involved in different
in designing different research projects
using publicly available data
so to provide hands-on training and to
make participants familiar
with the approach to design and complete
our research project
we are continuously designing different
research projects
based on publicly available data
uh which are published in well-known
journals
thus we have a collection of research
projects here you can learn
how bioinformatics can be applied in the
field of oncology
using these freely available datasets to
drive biological
and clinical important biomarker for
specific cancer conditions
so let me give you a glimpse of one
project where we focused on identifying
molecular signatures that are associated
with the clinical factors of the liver
cancer patients
based on integration of multi-omics data
here we explored different omics layers
that is
rna mi rna and clinical and demographic
characteristics
characteristics of the scc patients to
find out what are important molecular
signature that are associated with those
clinical phenotypes
like tumor stage risk factor age gender
etc
so there are number of the research
fellows who have completed their
research
project in the field of oncology with
pine biotech
research fellowship program
one of our research fellow miss simayat
dolana
a undergraduate student from turkey
recently completed her research
project entitled long non-coding rna as
therapeutic target
in cll that is chronic lymphocytic
leukemia
using publicly available data and
implementing various tools
that are available on t1 for server
then ms ursha parikh who is postgraduate
student from india
completed her research project in
identifying
identification of biomarker to
differentiate between neural stem cell
and glioblastoma step stem cell
using various tools on tbi info server
and implying data set take taken from
the public repository
next mr kala mari marul who is a phd
student
from city in mexico he is he has
completed his research project entitled
classification of triple negative breast
cancer cell line
by gene expression analysis of
transmembrane protein using machine
learning algorithm
based on available cell line data and
using
different tools from our various
platforms
i am looking forward of to being your
mentor in the upcoming comics logic
pre-season oncology program now i would
like pass this session to india so over
to you india
thank you dr harpreet and uh everyone
else that
had a chance already to present and um
i want to pick up on where all of this
kind of leads us to which is the program
itself
so up until now you've seen how to gain
access to the different resources
to see where you might see yourself
after you complete this program with an
independent project or
a better understanding of how
bioinformatics could be applied to
oncology research and also
some examples of real data sets that you
can have access to
as curated data sets or then potentially
a project of your own where you have to
identify
a new data set to do your own research
so what i want to speak to you today
about is the subject of today's session
which is
the introduction to this program but
before i do
let me introduce myself my name is elia
brodsky and i've
had the privilege of running hundreds of
online and on-site programs related to
bioinformatics
and we've done this with our
collaborators at universities such as
georgetown university
louisiana state university tulane
university of haifa
and many others and so as a result
i've seen thousands of students from all
backgrounds complete their training
and get empowered by bioinformatics
tools to participate in research studies
develop data-driven hypotheses for their
projects and go on to publish or present
their projects in poster review sessions
and so what i hope for all of you is
that this program will also help you in
your journey
whether you're only starting or have
already vast experience in oncology
so we hope that this program will be an
experience that will provide you with
new opportunities and skills
that will benefit you for years to come
so in this first session what we want to
do is kind of set the stage for
why we are learning about oncology and
what are specific
characteristics of cell and dna
and omics data that will be used in the
future sessions
so we'll talk about challenges
associated with big data in cancer
research
and then we'll talk about how next
generation sequencing data and other
types of high throughput data could be
used
to understand the biological processes
that lead to clinical manifestations of
cancer
so first let's talk about what is cancer
because cancer is one of the leading
causes
of morbidity and mortality worldwide
with almost 10 million people dying from
it per year
the cancer prevalence is the greatest in
the western world as you can see
on this map where you have close to six
percent of all people that have cancer
during their lifetime
in the us and worldwide there's an
approximately
40 percent of men and women that will be
diagnosed with cancer
at some point during their lifetime and
in 2020
an estimated 17 000 children
and adolescents ages between 0 and 19
will be diagnosed with cancer and
ultimately over 1700 young people
will die of this disease and so what we
can see from this data is that cancer
risk
increases dramatically with age but
there are other
also causes of cancer that include
abnormal weight
use of tobacco exposure to radiation
as well as many different types of viral
infections
in fact about five percent of all
cancers are caused by pathogens by
viruses
so the bottom line is that cancer is a
genetic disease
and it is caused by cancer causing or
driving genetic changes inherited
mutations play
a role in about five to ten percent of
all cancers and the rest
are associated with somatic mutations
and changes
in the regulation of cell development
so when we study cancer we essentially
can think about this
as a disease of cells and we can observe
the changes of cells from being normal
healthy
functioning that's that are similar to
other
cells in the tissue to becoming abnormal
or
deregulated cells that start to form
tumors or abnormal growth
and metastasize or spread to the other
parts of the body
and so we can see how this process takes
time
and so there is exist an urgent need to
identify
new biomarkers or signatures in
biological processes that can help us
with early detection prognosis and
appropriate treatment selection and so
this is what this program is going to be
all about
so in this session which is called
introduction to oncology
we'll talk about some of the biological
changes in organs tissues and cells
what are some of the molecular factors
that are associated with tumor
development growth and metastasis
and how can we view the relationship
between
clinical diagnosis of this disease and
the molecular data
that essentially causes this disease to
appear
and has to be studied in controlled
experiments oftentimes
with an association of what we have
available for the clinical
patient level data and so
this part of it this part of the program
is essentially a fundamental
introduction that many of you are
probably already familiar with
uh but you will kind of have a
refresh of some of those terms that we
will be using throughout this course
and hopefully that will help us think
about the significance of the data
and the analysis methods that we will
continue to use
in the future sessions of this program
so since we talked about cells
one of the primary things that cells go
through
are individual cycles of cell division
and so cell division is essential for
normal growth
and normal kind of development of an
organism as well as
in our after we kind of grow up and we
mature
as adults cell division continuous is a
continuous process and so it is
essential for life but it must be
controlled
and so when a cell divides it goes
through several cycles that are
regulated
by a special family of proteins and it
controls the progression of a cell
through the cell cycle by activating
cyclin-dependent kinase enzymes or
groups of the enzymes are required for
synthesis of the cell cycle
and so when we talk about the cancer
cells
they are essentially cells that have
gone wrong
so they no longer respond to many of the
signals that control
cellular growth and death and cancer
cells
originate within tissues and as they
grow and divide
they diverge further and further from
that normal state
and so over time these cells become
increasingly resistant
to the controls that maintain normal
tissue so they divide more rapidly
and their progenitors become less
dependent on signals from other cells so
they become
more and more disconnected from the rest
of the organism
and then they evade programmed cell
deaths
despite the fact that their multiple
abnormalities
would normally make them prime targets
for apoptosis
and in the late stages of cancer cells
break from normal tissue completely
they go outside of the boundary of that
tissue and eventually metastasize or
spread to new sides of the body
and so to help us think about this
process of cell deregulation
we can think of the different hallmark
features of cancer so as we said cancer
is
unchecked health growth mutations in
genes
can cause cancer by accelerating cell
division rates or inhibiting normal
controls on the system
such as cell cycle arrest or program
cell death
and as a mass of cancerous cell growth
it can develop into a tumor
and so when we think about these
hallmarks essentially
there are original six hallmarks of
cancer
one sustaining proliferative signaling
two evading growth suppressors three
activation of invasion and metastasis
four enabling replicative immortality
five inducing angiogenesis energetics
and six resisting cell death and so
in the recent time additional four
have been added such as deregulating
cellular energetics avoiding immune
destruction
tumor promoting inflammation and genome
instability and mutation
so here we observe the process
of a healthy cell that eventually
becomes
an invasive tumor and so we see this
as a complex condition that manifests in
changes to
cell regulation at many different levels
resulting in this abnormal growth that
we call
tumors these tumors consist of cells
whose growth and morphological
characteristics are very different from
normal cells and so criteria for
malignancy
would include some of those features
that we just talked about like cell
proliferation
loss of differentiation infiltrative
growth and metastasis
to other organs that we associate with
different stages of cancer
and so here you can see how the cells
develop over time
and one of the primary objectives of
oncology is to understand
the mechanisms behind such processes
that cause cancer's cancer cells to
emerge
and to grow and so when
30 years ago scientists could not even
offer
really a coherent answer to this
question about what is the cause
of these changes and they just knew that
cancer arose from cells
that began to all of a sudden
proliferate uncontrollably within the
body
and they knew that chemicals radiation
and viruses could trigger this change
but exactly what happened nobody really
knew just 30 years ago
but over the last three decades an
emergence of
data about these cells has
revolutionized our understanding of
cancer
and this is because we have different
techniques now of molecular biology
as well as data science that allow us to
generate data
from the dna and the rna and the
proteins
in these individual cells tissues and
organs
and associate them with specific
molecular factors
that could help us understand how this
process actually
evolves and so when we
see these cancer cells
we know that they are very different
right so for example how can we describe
this difference
one of the ways to describe them is
using phenotypic data or phenotype
and so we can look at their morphology
and how they
look and kind of try to categorize them
for example they have large
variably shaped nuclei they have many
dividing cells
that are disorganized and they're not
arranged in the same structure as a
tissue
they have a lot of different shapes and
sizes
and they essentially lose the normal
features that we associate
with cells that have a very defined
structure and
shape and so as a result of observing
these phenotypic changes we can
start asking the question well how is
this phenotype
as a result of a disrupted production
of cells which is regulated at different
levels of dna
rna and signaling and so we can then
start to understand some of the basic
internal
cellular factors that contribute to the
development of cancers
but what we know today is that the
cancer cells
inside the tumor also leverage some of
the cells
in the tumor and around the tumor and so
we can think of this
as a disease that affects the tumor
cells
as well as the tumor micro environment
because cancer cells
are able to ignore signals that normally
tell cells to stop dividing or that
beginning process known as
program death or apoptosis and so the
body uses this process to get rid
of unneeded cells but because they
stop responding to these signals
they also start affecting the cells
around them
and so one of the things that we have to
study is
the cellular mechanisms the interaction
between cells within a tumor that
actually contain many different cells
but then also to think about how do they
interact with the rest of the tissue
the rest of the organ and eventually
what causes them to go
beyond the tissue itself causing what's
called
invasion infiltration of other tissues
as well as metastases
now one of the other hallmarks that we
talked about was the evasion of the
immune response and so when we think of
cancer cells that stop right stop
uh responding to the regulation within
the cell
there are specific types of immune cells
that are supposed to recognize those
and attack them and so cancer cells
are known to evade this immune system
which is a network of organs tissues and
specialized cells that
protect the body from infections and
other conditions
and so normally the immune system would
remove damaged or abnormal cells from
the body
but some cancers are able to hide from
the immune system
and so there are two types of tumors hot
and cold tumors what are hot tumors hot
tumors
are those that show signs of
inflammation meaning the tumor has
already been
infiltrated by t cells rushing to fight
the cancerous cells so the tumor cells
have undergone many mutations that
create new antigens recognized by the t
cells so they can recognize them as
abnormal cells
now typically with the presence of
cancer-fighting cells or t-cells
we know that the immune system has
recognized them and is working to fight
and so for this reason hot tumors
typically respond well to immunotherapy
treatment
using checkpoint inhibitors because
those are present
and so the main idea behind checkpoint
inhibitors is to use antibodies to
mobilize even more t cell response
during the attack on the tumor t cells
become exhausted
and lose important functions needed to
kill tumor cells
and so the exhaustion is brought on by
constant exposure to tumor antigens
and signaling through checkpoint
receptors the antibodies block signaling
through these receptors to prevent this
loss of function so we'll look at a
project
where we can observe this loss of
function
in these macrophages what are the cold
tumors
some non-immunogenic cold tumors have
not yet been infiltrated by t cells and
so this is a sign that the immune system
is not working on one of for some reason
right so the lack of t
cells makes it difficult to provoke an
immune response with immunotherapy drugs
and so what we see at the cellular level
to the tissue level to the organ level
is that
these different characteristics of cells
at the molecular
and cellular level can help us diagnose
specific types of processes and try to
address them using
a number of innovative treatment options
so finally one of the main reasons
why cancer progresses to a late stage
and causes mortality
is because of metastasis and so
when cancer cells spread locally by
moving into
near normal tissue that's called
invasion
but then they can spread to nearby lymph
nodes
tissues or other organs and so as a
result
we see this metastasis of cells
in the whole body and so when you
observe
under a microscope metastatic cancer
cells have features
like the ones that the primary cancer
where they came from and not like the
cells
in the place where the cancer is found
so you can have for example
a metastatic cell come from the breast
and go
into lungs and so that is essentially a
breast cell that is causing cancer in
the lung
and so what we see here is a number of
insights that could be very critical for
our ability to
treat cancers and recognize them
understanding
the reasons or the drivers of this
progression
okay so any questions so far about what
we have covered
if you have any questions we recommend
putting those
in the chat box so again if anyone has
any questions
about the process that we described here
at the biological level
if you have any questions about the
program itself you can use
the chat box to write those out
another resource that is important is
that we have
a slack channel for those that have
completed their registration to the
precision oncology program
so if you put any questions that you
would like us to address
in our next session please add those to
the slack channel
with a tag question right so if we
have a number of questions for our next
session we'll be able to reflect on the
material that we've covered today
and continue on to speak about uh the
additional material
so what are we going to speak about
okay and so here we already have a
question describe more about
checkpoint inhibitors in immunotherapy
so
great question now we have to speak
about
what are the methods that we have
to identify these specific changes
how signaling or the genetic regulation
of different types of expressed proteins
happens within the cell so let me talk
about that
and sakshan if you are already a part of
the program
please add your question to the forum on
slack and we will start with that
question in our next session
okay so when we speak about
the ways the methods to understand what
is going on
one of the things that we have one of
the technologies that allows us to study
these processes at the subcellular level
in other words
inside the cell are techniques like next
generation sequencing so next generation
sequencing is essentially the process
of taking the genetic material from
within the cell
of multiple cells within the tissue
extracting it
and converting it to digital data so
essentially we can survey
what exactly is happening at a given
snapshot in each cell
and this could be done using a variety
of what's called
omics data so amic data
includes phenomics genomics
epigenomics and transcriptomics and omix
technologies like next generation
sequencing can be used to explore the
roles relationships and actions of the
various types of molecules that make up
the cells
of an organism so for example here you
can see
phenomics right so it's a collection of
automated
ways to categorize cells for example we
talked about
cell morphology right so this could
represent some kind of a phenotype
that we associate with a given cancer
cell genomics or the data
that represents the sequence of the dna
genomic data represents either the
individual nucleotides
or the sequence rearrangements or the
variation
in segments like chromosome
rearrangements so when we talk about
genomic data
we'll look at mutations copy number
variation
and rearrangement then we can talk about
epigenomics or the way that this data
in the dna could be silenced or made
more available for reading
using a variety of epigenetic regulation
mechanisms such as
small micro rnas long non-coding rnas
and other types of methylation and
immunohis and sorry changes to
the chromatin right so we'll talk about
some of the role of the epigenomic data
that can reveal
those uh regulation patterns and
mechanisms
and finally we have the ability to
measure
expression levels so we can ask the
question which
proteins essentially are going to be
produced
by looking at their proxy or the mrna so
we can
look at the whole spectrum of omix
technologies
using the sequencing technology of next
generation sequencing
and start asking questions what is
happening to the cell
what does that mean at the genomic level
how is it regulated at the epigenomic
level and what is the result of that
regulation on
what is being produced and so as a
result
what we want to do in this program is
take a
a look at examples of basic and
translational oncology research projects
that will take
a look at single cell patient-derived
cell line
projects that will look at systems level
patient-derived xenograft models and
finally look at real patient data where
we can
get data from clinical trials and a
variety of translational projects that
will
help us understand the relationship
between comorbidities risk factors
individual people or patients
and how we can use all of that data
together for a variety of translational
applications
okay and i'll pause here just to answer
the question so what are
cell lines cell lines are essentially
cells taken from tumors of individual
patients
that are then immortalized
and could be grown in a lab instead of
in a body they could be grown in a petri
dish
and so you can see individual cells that
represent essentially what
happens in an organism to a certain
degree of what we can tell about
a cell so
as we gain access to these different
data sets there's also a variety of
different
challenges that are arising from this
availability of data so as you can see
here on the graph
uh starting from the uh you know 2010
approximately we have this dramatic
increase
in the availability of public data but
it comes with also
additional challenges one of the
challenges that this data is very
variable and very
specific to individual projects
essentially that generated
it's also huge the data sets are fairly
large if you take
one next generation sequencing data set
that might have between several to maybe
hundreds of samples you're talking about
gigabytes to terabytes of data
and so what's important about being able
to handle such data to process it
is that in this program we want to
introduce you to some resources
that will allow you to perform
computation of huge data sets
using cloud-based resources and
leverage them to essentially develop
structured data out of these publicly
available datasets so how
are we going to do that in each case
when we talk about genomics epigenomics
transcriptomics proteomics
we're talking about data sets that are
contained in
packages of short reads or
elements that have to be pieced together
to represent
a structured data set that we could
actually analyze and so one of the
things that we will do in this program
is we will take this raw data so what
you can see here are
individual reads mapped to a reference
genome
and so we'll look at this raw data to
try to understand
how we can detect in this raw data
specific signal
and that signal could be variance so
specific positions at the dna level that
have a mutation or a change
we will look at the processing
quantification
and performing statistical analysis of
mrna
expression data including processing
that data from raw reach to a table of
expression
and asking the question how can we
compare different conditions
to see changes within specific genes
and we'll also think about how do we
leverage big databases where we can use
annotation on gene ontology terms and
pathways so that we can understand
how this information the signal that we
find in the data
could be turned into biologically
interpretable information
okay um
okay and so we'll talk about the
schedule here in just a second
thank you sylvia for the question but
let me first
show you how we can use this resource
for big data analysis
that will allow us to essentially uh
study such data
so please go with me to a link
server that t-bio that info
and beeps if you could please post the
link
as well as the demo details
so this is a platform a cloud-based
platform
for big data analysis where you can
analyze large data sets from public
repositories like the ncbi
or tcga the cancer genome atlas
by uploading data directly from these
public
repositories or using data sets that
we'll be
uh providing you with these are curated
data sets that you can use
to perform analysis yourself and so the
first thing that we want to do
is look at one demo pipeline
so this is a pipeline that will
illustrate how the system works
and you will see how logic of analysis
will be clear to you after just this one
exercise okay so please put
number one in the chat box if you have
gotten to this platform and you see what
i see on the screen
okay so please put number one i'll just
give it a moment for everybody to get
here
okay thank you reg nish norman
mushumi okay let's give it just another
minute for
a few more people to get to this link
now once you get here you can log in
either using
account details that have been provided
to you by email
for those that have registered to the
program
and please make sure to add marketing at
pine bio to your
contact list because you will be
receiving emails about important account
information after the session
or you can use the demo account to log
in
all right great so we have a few people
that are already here so
right now if you don't have an account
you can use the demo
so right here under transcriptomics you
want to click
on this arrow and let's go to this
first one demo rna seek cell line
project
so once you click on that link you will
see this pipeline
this pipeline combines a number of steps
organized into logical groups by
what you see in this frame like air
correction exon detection mapping on
genome etc
and now what we'll do is build a
pipeline so we'll essentially connect
the series of scripts together to
convert data from raw format
which is individual reads into a
structure format which is
a table of expression so first of all i
will click
on start and you can see how these
logical steps are organized
into a sequence first we do
pre-processing where
technical variation is removed from
individual read sequences
then we perform mapping where you align
those reads to the reference genome
and then we quantify the levels of
expression so we ask the question
how much of a given mrna is present
in the sample let's click on ok
as you can see i have a number of
options that are now highlighted
trim-o-matic bow tie 2g top hat 2
hi-sat-2 and bow type t so based on the
logic that we just discussed
pre-processing mapping and
quantification
what do you think should be the next
step for me to take
which button should i click on next
remember it was
pre-processing mapping
and quantification which one should i
choose
pre-processing okay so which step
specifically what does that button
say on it which button should i click on
so as you can see pre-processing you've
correctly identified it as a whole
okay great section trimmermatic right
it's the only
one here so let's click on trimomatic
okay let's
learn about what does trimomatic
actually do how is it a pre-processing
step
so trimmermatic you can scroll down here
and it says trimmermatic algorithm
cleans technical sequences from a
database which stores sequences known to
be used as adapters in next-generation
sequencing experiments
from raw sequencing data so what is raw
sequencing data
individual reads and what sequences are
present there are specific
sequences that will align to
a database and we know that there are
going to be
technical sequences adapters and
sequences that essentially all of these
will be trimmed right so
we go through all of our individual
reads and trim sequences
that are not representative of the true
biological signal
in our data so this is traumatic so
after we
click on trumatic we have another one
pop-up which is called pcr
clean which addresses the step of uh
this bridge amplification we'll talk a
lot more about this in our next session
and after we've done some pre-processing
we now have
mapping on transcripts so essentially
we're going to map those reads
onto a reference transcriptome
and then we will produce a level of
expression or
quantification so we will quantify for
each gene that we have
in the human genome for example we will
give it an expression level
and so using this rsem method
that will produce a table of expression
we can now click on end
and if you just wait a little bit you
will get here
some of the outputs from this pipeline
so please go ahead and explore this
pipeline
the outputs that we see here to
understand how
processing will help us produce
structured data
on thousands or hundreds or tens
of samples and thousands of genes
so this is something that we'll use in
the context of specific projects so you
probably saw that the project data set
that we have there
is called cell lines data and so
together with the cell lens data we have
a variety
of different projects as you can see
right here and we hope that in the
process
of this program you will also develop a
project of your own so learning from
these examples that are taken from
top peer-reviewed publications in
application to cancer
we'll see how you can develop a project
of your own
or potentially add on to what's already
in the data set that is described here
and so here we can see some of the
examples
at the level of predicting response
or outcome of for different cancers
discovering
novel ideas and hypotheses about the
risk factors
and even potentially developing novel
intervention methods and so
just to give you a sense of how this
will be done
here's an example of one of those
projects called
modeling precision treatment of breast
cancer
this is a data set from a publication
that was published in 2013
and it's interesting because here the
authors assembled
a collection of samples with multi-omics
data
that could help predict drug response
in another project as you already heard
dr harpridka or describe her experience
with
the cancer genome atlas we will go to
the cancer genome atlas which has
samples from
thousands of patients across a variety
of tumor types
and we'll start asking the question
about specific
types of clinical information that we
have
and phenotypic information that we have
about those patients
and we'll go into the publication to
understand
what novel information has been
extracted from this collection of
patient data
associated with molecular data that can
help answer questions
about specific aspects of heptacellular
carcinoma
like drivers of heptacellular carcinoma
different stages and biomarkers of
subtypes
as well as some of the response
different treatments
so what we'll do in this program is we
will talk about
cancer biology including the central
dogma of molecular biology the
biological hallmarks of cancer
the approaches to cancer diagnostic and
treatment selection
to the understanding of the biological
factors of the tumor itself as well as
its micro
environment and heterogeneity and the
regulation
and targets in specific biological
pathways
that could provide the provide us with a
good understanding
of biological factors associated with
this disease
now we'll also talk about bioinformatics
methods like processing next-generation
sequencing data
variant calling the application of rna
seek analysis statistical analysis like
hypothesis testing and regression
machine learning including clustering
principal component analysis
and classification and annotation of
gene set
gene ontology terms and keg pathway
and then finally we'll introduce you in
detail
two curated data sets from these
exampler projects and these include
projects from cell lines the patient
derives xenograft models of tumor and
stroma interaction where a tumor is
engrafted into an
animal mouse model the cancer genome
atlas or tcga
that will allow us to think about
clinical risk factors and outcomes
and also think about different types of
therapeutics for different
sub sub subtypes and stages of cancer
but we'll also talk about how to find
additional data on ncbi and tcga
and how to structure your bioinformatics
project
so now to answer sylvia's question and
to talk about
the program's schedule and how to gain
access to all of these resources
i will pass it back on to beeps and this
was to talk about
the program schedule
thank you elia uh for sharing this
wonderful
overview of what we are going to be
doing in the upcoming program and now
let me
introduce you to the omixlogic resources
that we will utilize during this entire
training period
the program will leverage our top rated
online tutorials using the
learn.omixlogic.com portal
with smart tracking activity and curated
data sets designed
for great learning experience
and throughout the course you will be
given directions to access the tbi info
platform
for bioinformatics processing and
analysis
of rna-seq data the platform will
include demo pipelines
like we saw today as well as data
management and analysis
cloud infrastructure to run
bioinformatics pipelines
different stages of analysis will be
performed in different sections
of this multi-omics platform
and in this program we will be using
a research bioinformatics analysis to
help you develop
a logical understanding of key methods
involved in preparation of such data
and behind many of the methods are also
scripts written in popular coding
languages such as
r and python these are also explained in
tutorials you will have access to in
form
of the code omics logic platform from
visualization of genomic data to
exploratory analysis and hypothesis
testing
and if you have not checked out the
precision oncology link here is a
snapshot of all the sessions that we
will cover
so to answer sylvia's question we are
going to be having
sessions on monday wednesday and friday
at the same time which is 10 a.m cst
and if you are looking forward to join
the program
this is the link so let me take you
back to the website again and show you
how you can
join this program so this is the link to
join the program
i will be sharing the link in the chat
box if you have not yet registered for
the program the registration is still
open
and you can go ahead and see what the
program is about we have also added the
different
dates and the session topics here so you
can actually see
what is the next session that we are
going to be having
and to register for the program uh once
you click on get started i'll go there
again
you will find there are three different
licenses
so as we are beginning i'll just again
explain what these three licenses
are the beginner license gives you
access to all
of these resources that we discussed
today
and the sessions as well as the slack
channel
and the project resources while the
intermediate license
gives you an access to a mentor who you
can meet one-on-one
every week to discuss any questions that
you may have
or to discuss your project while the
advanced license
gives you an additional 50
30 days sorry not 15 days additional 30
days
to work on your project with our team
of research fellows as well as
collaborate with any participant
so as you know that the program is
ending on 9th of april
and we will give everybody an extension
till april 16th
post that from april 16th to may 16th
anybody with an advanced license can
actually go ahead and work on their
project so they will
continue with their access to the
resources
as well as the program so i hope that
this would be clear for everybody so let
me go
back to the presentation
i hope that you have been able to review
all the different dates
for the session as well and now
i would like to invite clinton to talk a
little bit more
about what is the outcome that every
participant will have
after they complete this training so
clinton over to you
thank you
so as
seen in some of the earlier
presentations
we will learn important concepts within
cancer biology such as the central dogma
the hallmarks how cancer is diagnosed
and treated
we will talk about several
bioinformatics methods
such as processing variant calling
rna-seq and more
finally we will look at sample projects
to learn how to make your own projects
by learning these concepts you will
you will be well structured to start
your own projects for
future analysis
so the learning outcomes is as follows
you will learn to read and understand
bioinformatics literature
perform basic ngs analysis
form hypotheses related to
bioinformatics
questions prepare data for machine
learning
cross-check actual signals or actual
data with other gene databases
know what type of data is required to
answer those scientific questions create
your own bioinformatic
analyses slash pipelines present
your and finally present your results in
an organized way
all all these skills are essential in
bioinformatics
and some can be translated to other
fields
after achieving the learning outcomes
you will
you would have learned some of the major
best practices in the field of
bioinformatics
you will be exposed to r and python
two powerful programming languages
bioinformaticians will need to
understand
how to use t-test regression and other
tests
analyzing and managing data you
also learn how to analyze and manage
data in order to communicate
important information to other
individuals
pipeline development and utilization is
another
common best practice within the field of
bioinformatics
ultimately completing the precision
oncology program
will help you enter the field of
bioinformatics since you learn
you will learn several best practices
so now i would like to pass it back to
beep shop
to talk more about the registration and
form
thank you so much clinton and the chat
box is now open for any questions and
while
we are doing this i would want to know
more about
everybody who is present here in today's
meeting
so now you'll find a poll on your screen
i hope everybody can see the poll and
there are a few questions that we have
for you the first question is
what is your current country of
residence
and if you are from any of the other
countries which are not
listed around here you can also post
them in the chat box
the second question is what is your
current level of education
again if these levels of education are
not mentioned
you can also mention the others right in
the chat box
what is your area of interest or
specialization
again you can also write about any other
area of specialization
which is not pertaining to oncology
and the fourth question that we have is
what are your objectives in learning
about precision oncology
so there are a few
topics to choose from if you are a
beginner and you have an interest in
cancer research
so you would want to learn more about
precision oncology you already work
on cancer research and want to implement
bioinformatics to your research
you find the topic interesting or you're
not interested in oncology at all
so you have all of these options to
please go ahead
and
i'll keep this on for one more minute
and then i'll go back to the
presentation
and meanwhile as you are going forward
with the poll
please make sure that you also post
you also post the questions in the
session yes and i think david
uh i'm sure i'm getting your name
correct so we did have the introduction
to oncology at the session
did you join in early i did not see your
message and as you're joining him if
you're participating in the session
what would be great is for us to know
more about who you are so if you can
always have your full name on
that would be really really helpful
okay so i will be ending the
poll right now that you see on the
screen
and next again what we would want
everybody to start with
is sign up to learn dot omics logic to
get started
and you know we have already spoken
about the slack platform that every
participant
will have access to who have joined this
training so you can post
any of the questions that you have
regarding the session right there
as well as we have our linkedin page
and our facebook group that you can also
post in
and once you complete the training we
will also give you a certificate like
this
and these are some of the details
regarding the training program
and we have already gone through this
one so please feel free to check out the
link
on how to join this training
so in our previous program we have seen
participants have completed the training
successfully like
olga udatseva here who is a postdoctoral
research fellow at
roswell park cancer center and used her
experience
to learn about data analysis techniques
which she is now
applying in her own pre-clinical
research
and like olga there have been several
other participants who have
taken part in different omics logic
programs that we
offer and have been very successful at
them
and once you complete the program
you will receive a certificate of
participation that you can
use on your resume or link to your
profile
that shows all of your achievements
and this is why our previous program
participants like mikhail here
rang the omixlogic programs as a talk
based on program
interactivity personal feedback support
and the quality of projects you will be
able
to achieve leveraging the resources we
make available
and mikhail has shared this very
interesting review
so i will again go back and share this
review with everyone here
so that you all can also take a look at
what he has to say
about and the omixlogic programs right
now
and while we are here please make sure
that if you are
joining the program again this is the
link to join
and we just want to mention that we also
offer scholarships for students
who require them so if you are someone
who
is interested in applying for
a scholarship so please go to this link
right here
and you can apply for the scholarship so
once you apply
and fill up the form right here you
would receive an email from our end
where we would ask you to set up a
meeting with one of your references
so based upon that meeting it is decided
whether you are
going to receive the scholarship or not
but please feel free to go ahead and
fill out
this form right here if you are
interested in applying
and i do hope that you
have if you have any questions you'll be
posting them
in the chat box so in the upcoming
session
we will discuss the types of information
that can be extracted from next
generation sequencing
data and you will learn about how to
process analyze and interpret genomic
data through specific pipelines
example techniques will include variant
calling mapping and finding the
significance of specific mutations
these are the common techniques used in
hospitals to analyze sequencing data
from cancer patients
in hopes to diagnose and potentially
design an
effective treatment plan with this skill
set
and a few project worth of experience
you could also
be potentially on the path to help a
hospital near you or become a
bioinformatician who works
on cancer research so now the session is
again open for
any questions that you may have please
feel free to ask us any questions
okay and you can also see the poll
results right now
on your screen so i see that
we have about eight percent of people
who are from the us
23 percent from mexico and
eight percent again from peru we also
have a large number of
participants today who are not from u.s
so we also have here in the chat
nigeria iraq
and bangladesh what is your current
level of education so most of the
participants here hold a bachelor degree
or
are in the undergraduate program while
23 percent are in master's degree 15
percent in phd
while 15 percent are also faculty
while there are others who also are
compromising of 15 percent
an area of interest or specialization so
54 percent
present here are of course
well into precision oncology or oncology
as a whole
while 23 percent are interested in
buying for matrix
the rest are undecided or interested in
something else
you can also write about those interests
right down in the chat box
what are your objectives in learning
about decision oncology
so you are a beginner and your interest
is in cancer research
69 percent have said that they are a
beginner
i work on cancer and want to implement
biofuel matrix
so that is comprising of 31 percent
while we do not have anyone else for the
rest of the
fields listed there so thank you all for
sharing again
again if you have any question we will
let you know
so i are you already registered for the
program so this was the only free
session that we have as part of the
bi-informatics for precision oncology
program for the upcoming one-month
program you would have to register
for the full program to gain access to
those sessions all participants
will receive an email and the sessions
please note this the sessions will start
at
10 a.m cst so if you have missed out or
joined later
please review the video that we will be
emailing you
and sending it to you and we will also
share those videos
in the slack channel so that you are
able to review them
later as well
and if you have any other questions
please let us know